vous étiez grégory lacroix et david
brécourt c'était alias le docteur
baptiste mondino alors on dira calme un
petit mot sur la série c'était 14
saisons 480 épisodes 480 heures diffusé
dans 135 pays sous le nom au centre de
saint tropez pardon oui 40 % de part de
marché auprès des ménagères de moins de
cinquante ans voilà c'est vous dire
c'était hallucinant et on appelait tonya
kinzinger qui vous fait un gros bisou
qui ne pouvait pas être là parce qu'elle
est en tournage actuellement les guest y
en a eu tellement francs ghetto
betteraves angelini après hugo frais
grégory basso sophie favier patrice
laffont amanda lear bref au caire c'est
bernard qui
l'a été ce soir là il avait fait des
tests pour voir quel était le mot qui me
suggérait le plus et le mieux la salle
tromper à l'étranger dont il m'a tout
bêtement saint tropez patron part
j'aimerais qu'on recommence quand même
avec forcément le docteur baptiste
mondino c'était le séducteur au début il
est séduit par laure et puis finalement
il termine en couple avec jessica te
dire qu'ils singer voilà donc vous vous
démarrez dans cette série vous c'est
quoi c'est un casting on vous appelle
clairement par hasard exactement vous
savez pas mais aussi des lignes on sait
pas du tout ce que va donner la syrie le
propos le la thématique je ne sais pas
trop voilà un essai deux essais à bon
ben alors si petite anecdote assez
amusant comme à raconter c'est que ces
lamelles là je sais pas tu te souviens
fred véronique courjault oui la
productrice exécutive de la série donc
mais mes essais sont bâties à tf1
c'était fin qui a choisi et où il paraît
que la plaque bleue la fille est passé
d'environ tf1 elle a entendu ma voix la
fève et bien lui en prend elle m'a même
pas regardé ouais d'après uniquement
pour la voie barrée et si elle vous avez
regardé en plus et la devons rester 18
ans quand elle et vivre 10 ans 15 ans a
trompé c'est bon il parait que les fans
après c'est un peu le problème du
syndrome navarro a que moi de faire
sauter les pv et parec vous ensuite les
fans bas vous demander de vous soigner
pas des était médecin pour
fouler la le paie un jour je footing
tous les deux ans j'ai eu je me suis
vraiment très très bien entendu avec
tonia ont joué marine d'un amour là
c'est une fille super on a on a bossé on
a on a vraiment on travaille en amont je
voyais le soin pour travailler le texte
est
c'est une fille formidable questions et
attend juste avant que ce qui est très
drôle c'est que vous avez tous les
talents parce que dans la série vous
êtes cancérologue neurologue
obstétriciens non mais c'est faute sur
sa
colonne
de mec est quand même très brillant
quand même à la haine et avons connu de
parler j'aimerais courir dans cet
extrait quand même voilà du docteur
baptiste un accouchement
[Musique]
si ce n'est sur patins sur la maladie
professionnelle tel flot perry et je
m'occupe jeu culte mais tu sais ce que
tu en es tu as d'opérer la boe pas
l'opérer vous non moi je suis pas
habilité à opérer une chirurgie en garde
est déjà en pleine intervention demander
même pas qui a tiré et principal c'est
un sommet dans
la défense de s'en sortir parce qu'il
est roux ce rite halal et y va la faire
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine que vous étiez dans des villas
à saint tropez pendant 15 ans piscine
est tous logés comme les stars n'ont
alors c'est pas moi c'est pas duré 15
ans il ya eu le début je suis reparti
avec toujours le théâtre qui était
omniprésente où tu en es et puis après
un moment donné j'ai passé trois quatre
ans mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
fred on arrivait dans des villas à lui
sinon
moi maintenant je crois pas c est ce que
quelqu'un sait pas que vous trouviez en
hiver on y va du coup parce qu'on ait
moins de monde mais qu'on aime c'est
toujours en maillot de bain mais en fait
je faisait froid et nos revenus après
sur ma vie relève désormais de fin
septembre à fin novembre et on reprenait
début mars jusqu'au moins le début juin
et c'est vrai que bon bah on mettait en
mettez les filles ont du boulot pour
elle était bleu les pauvres
c'était un moon boots et le quitte et
moonboots pour rentrer dans la flotte
mais alors arrêtez tout en portant haut
débit d'eau de la vérité maintenant vous
étiez jeune beau saint tropez il va les
boîtes de nuit séduit non mais
autre anecdote c'est qu'au début on sait
pas où on allait on sait pas elle
saint-tropez ont démarré on sait pas si
la série allait durer vingt ans wayne
ont beaucoup joué et la paix et on est
arrivé au mois de septembre mais il est
encore super chaud et on a fait la fête
mais comme des malades touchant semble
d'ailleurs je crois que on m'a mis un
peu à l'écart sur la série pendant six
mois en disant va proposer un simple
quand même là pour travailler et on
partait dans tous les sens tout le monde
faisait la fête et c'est un souvenir
souvenir mémorable alors j'imagine que
c'est formidable mais je pense toujours
à peter falk effet colombo et qu'il
dînait c'est la pire chose qui me soit
arrivée dans ma vie parce que je suis
colombo avis rien faire d'autre dans la
ruche et coloniaux pour les halles
réalisateur chez colombo pour les
producteurs ce colombo est ce que vous
vous êtes un très beau médecin et
aujourd'hui encore pour jouer c'est
c'est compliqué dans la rue vous êtes
docteur bécaud
encore un petit peu cc c'est marrant
c'est par phases il ya les moments
pendant un an ya plus rien qu'hier tout
d'un coup c'est tous les jours
curieux mais encore nommé si le métier
en revanche n'est fait encore confiance
pour d'autres rôles où vous êtes trop
marrer c'est à dire que non non non pas
du tout non non ça se passe très belle
truc si je fais beaucoup de théâtre
beaucoup de théâtre voilà donc ça ça me
prend beaucoup de temps là je viens de
certains cassandre par exemple avait
beaucoup de beaucoup de joie beaucoup de
bonheur et voilà quoi non non non c est
l entente entre tous parce que ils
payent c'était un peu compliqué avec
adeline blondieau c'est vrai ça ou pas
pas du tout
ouais monsieur
eric alors j'irai sur fer allongé récent
plein d'après à leurs questions sans
langue de bois stea longtemps est-ce
qu'on était bien payé
je me dis que c'est plus bas non mais on
était on est tous venant on était je
pense que la même série bones la même
série aux états unis bon ne répondra
gagner parfois plus oui ils étaient
payés n'ont normalement vraiment
vraiment maintenant c'est pas d'en haut
si on échoue finalement on était à peu
près à 2004 par journée on tournait pas
tous les jours ouais donc mais jean
deysel
mais c'était des conditions gigantesque
vous avez vécu quand même dix ans entre
amis à saint tropez de la mini-série
cartonnait s'attelle pas dans les
centres de maintenance et surtout c'est
surtout que j'ai appris mon métier j'ai
appris à tourner et on a commencé cette
série ont tourné en 16 mm et c'était
super quoi voile il ya tout tout mes
potes qui faisait rad a vite tendance au
soleil un fait attention reste pas trop
longtemps et où finalement il venait
tourner faire un geste il voulait pour
partie un wiki trouvé ça génial parce
que j'ai appris à tourner maintenant sur
un tournage je suis à l'aise j'ai appris
mon boulot voilà c'est tout alaba
effectivement et là il ya frédéric de
banquette avec nous également voilà
frédéric vous étiez frère de louis
rêveur solitaire rêve de parcourir le
monde en catamaran est amoureux de l'or
voilà donc ces voix là c'est un homme
solitaire tout ça c'est un papa comme le
médecin alors vous pareil comment vous
avez vécu un petit peu l'arrivée dans la
série est ce que vous vous êtes bien
entendu et tout le monde est ce que c
est ce que c'est les mêmes joli souvenir
que pour
mon arrivée dans la série elle s'est
faite après une grosse série qui avait
très bien marché sur tf1 qui s'appelait
des coeurs brûlés
ah là là là on était sur
14 millions de téléspectateurs vendredi
c'est l'énorme et puis après ça il ya eu
un creux comme quand on a un personnage
très marquant dans une série en règle
générale et une casting directrice est
passée j'étais en terrasse de place de
clichy du wepler et y chercher le rôle
de grégory lacroix ouais alors il avait
déjà tourné un pilote avec sagamore
stévenin qu'ils n'avaient pas voilà ça
n'avait pas la chaîne n'avait pas été
convaincu et moi je vais rencontrer
romeo serfaty sur une famille formidable
un an avant et voilà c'était pour jouer
le frère de roméo donc
j'ai dit oui je suis allé à la prod
quand ils nous ont vus ensemble avec
roméo ils ont dit oui de suite je n'ai
même pas fait d'excès je crois c'est
parti directement ces partis direct et
vous vous avez fait toutes les saisons
non j'ai fait très peu d'épisodes
j'en ai tourné que 40 pourquoi parce que
1 parce que j'avais d'autres choses à
tournai à côté je tournais les fils du
maître de chai pour la deux accords et
puis aussi parce que
je n'aime pas rester longtemps à la même
place
dabo êtes-vous je sors
compliqué alors c'est avec vous que
c'était un petit peu plus compliqué avec
les red line oui enfin ça si ça s'est
dit un peu sur les plateaux ouais
vous savez mathieu g je suis un peu
aller dans le sens du vent c'est à dire
quand on avait envie de me faire dire
des choses je suis pas un gars un garçon
contrariant
donc vous pouvez me dire ça s'est très
bien passé
on n'est pas du tout ça se passe super
bien en même temps mathieu sur des
équipes pareil on n'est pas obligé
d'aimer tout le monde pour s'éclairer
voilà et donc il est vrai qu'à de l'inrs
et moi on se ressemble beaucoup
du point de vue du caractère voilà c'est
mon double au féminin je suis son double
masculin donc forcément c'était pas avec
elle que je m'éclatais le plus mais à
part ça je veux pas de mal je l'emmenais
mais ce sont toujours ces que vous vous
êtes venu tony amedi tout de suite je
viens tout de suite aline à l'apa vous
la rose il faisait des années un peu
elle a refusé un peu derrière elle m'a
dit j'ai plus envie d'en parler voile
sur et ici peut-être scellé voilà les
gens les gens vivent voilà comment on
rêvait d'élèves sur instagram pour en
parler s'inquiéteront oui
comment on vit cette célébrité quand
elles arrivent de manière aussi
importante quand même alors il avait
bien vécu ou non j'avais déjà été
échaudé par les coeurs brûlés un oui
déjà déjà avec mary d'arc oui avec mais
je jouais quand même sans son mec ont
rien fait rien 1 c'est pas le de long
comment le de long c'est ça s était
d'autant plus fort que moi j'ai commencé
ma carrière avec delon dans parole de
flic
donc voilà trouvé ce rôle de sylvain
l'âge de 30 ans c'est ce que je
recherchais mais je m'attendais
absolument pas à me retrouver là ni dans
les bras ni dans l'île mireille darc
ça le fait quand même c'est votre vous
avez une longue carrière et vous aussi
mais c'est votre plus beau souvenir
quand même cette série ou pas du tout
vous parlez de sous le soleil ou de
soleil non non non ils n'ont pas rigolé
quand mon plus beau souvenir non de
tournage ouais non non pas du c'est pas
moi c'est pas du tout un mauvais
souvenir mais c'est un souvenir alors
c'est une série c'est un souvenir
épisodique et parce que il ya eu
tellement tellement de four on le dit
que la série allait revenir revenir
revenir et vos noms sont revenus aussi
si par hasard la série devait revenir
est composé comme dans friends vingt ans
après tout ça vous y retourneriez ou pas
du tout quotas page est tournée s'est
tournée moi je ferme la porte à rien
ouais rien du tout alors à tuer vous
savez
on sait pas de quoi demain va être fait
donc moi je sors d'une période où j'ai
traversé cinq ans de handicap mais vous
le savez enfin j'en ai parlé un peu
partout ouais on vend pas dans un
instant effectivement voir qu'on peut en
parler maintenant c'est qu'effectivement
il ya et vous avez perdu l'audition
total total à l'âge de 50 ans j'ai pris
une bouteille dans la tête et le
lendemain plus rare c'est ça ouais
d'accord il y avait des bagarres comme
chez un peu vague à de bakker suffit d
une tarte à quelqu'un qui m'a vous l'a
rendu ce qui m'a envoyé une bouteille
dans la tête voilà le lendemain plus
rien plus de son plus rien à part un
avion dans la tête qui était un
acouphène mais je ne savais pas que
c'était à l'époque et donc ça m'a coupé
de tout de mon métier de voilà de ma vie
sociale de ma vie amoureuse de ma vie
sexuelle de ses atours affleck quoi sert
un tsunami et il a fallu que je me
reconstruise ce que j'ai fait par le
biais de l'écriture dans un premier
temps et puis d'un seul ancien que j'ai
écris parce que je ne pouvais plus
exercer mon métier à la collégiale
donc je me suis dit merde comment tu
fais il faut que tu continues à jouer et
c'est ce que j'ai fais d'abord à paris
et puis maintenant au festival d'avignon
où je vais jouer l journal l'homme à
l'entendre et ces malentendus et je suis
le plus heureux des hommes intervenu le
18 mai à une audition est revenu il faut
opérer alors je suis fait implanter
d'accord c'était la seule possibilité
pour moi mais à l'époque je ne voulais
pas parce que sous le soleil était
encore diffuser sa rapport avec j'arrive
oui un rapport à l'excuser moi j'ai un
rapport avec l'image quand même donc les
hommes arrêtés dans la rue pour faire
des ciels fier je me voyais pas avec un
truc sur la tête pour faire des sales
fille mais comme je le dis dans dont une
seule en scène
je parle de cet homme parce que
finalement pour avoir réussi à raconter
cette histoire je les transportait sur
quelqu'un d'autre donc je parle de
l'homme et à un moment
je dis j'ai hésité longtemps avant de me
faire implanter et j'me la pète je fais
question d'image d'image mais qu'est ce
que l'image quand on n'a pas des sons
voilà donc au bout de trois ans j'ai
accepté quand même de le faire parce que
j'ai vu que ça n'était pas possible de
pouvoir faire mon seul en scène j'ai
d'ailleurs commencé à travailler avec
david la fin de ma question aussi c est
ce que vous voyez encore est ce que l on
rêvait aussi un peu tout et médéric
delmas télévision risque il ya parfois
des petites réunions d'anciens d'anciens
combattants dans la débine et houmadi
nous c'est le théâtre qui nous rassemble
et son adorable a dès qu'on est sur
scène elle de nous voir à chaque fois
oui c'est l'occasion de se voir à chaque
fois et mais voilà elles ont elles ont
elles aussi réussissent très bien
bénédicte elle réalise c'est une
formidable réalisatrice actuellement
mais l'état d'esprit est là ça va je
l'appelle elle est adorable elle répond
et tout mais très discrète est vraiment
montré alors on va parler vous dans un
instant mais ça qu'on a montré un
extrait de david brécourt dans la série
chamakh on vous voit vous aussi on va
pas me reconnaître le sûr je n'irai pas
bouger vous savez le charme ne bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sérieux c'est rigolo et était très
pieuse à ce qui paraît laquelle
travaille on les appelait on est happé
big delmas tout le monde n'apprécie
guère même si elle ne brille pas venir
nous a répondu il pas qu'elle détestait
quand on embrasse est-ce que vous avez
davin la moustache oui cette pierre et
c'était difficile c'est ça la elle a une
peau très fine art et donc elle marque
était tout rouge
mais c'est vrai mais c'est ça les
coulisses j'ai un fond de barbe qui as
est assez rugueux quoi c'est vrai
qu'elle avait des plaques alors au début
je me posais des questions je pense
qu'un peu énergique a marre mais pas du
tout elle m'a expliqué très vite en
revanche je viens de découvrir une chose
quoi je me souvenais évidemment du
plongeon de la mariée mais je me
souvenais absolument pas avoir mois
plongé dans l'eau ah oui si vous jouez
bien vous n'avez découvrir c'est un beau
plongeon d'ailleurs ouais
c'est cool et qui sonne chroniqueur mais
je crois aussi que vous pas de ce qu'on
m'a dit quand on a préparé l'après
interview vous avez un petit peu du mal
à à gérer pas cette célébrité mais
l'argent peut-être tout ce que vous avez
gagné vous l'avais un peu flambée
c'était difficile à gérer c'est vrai ça
mais mathieu c'est fait pour ça l'argent
c'est important absolument
mais je sais toujours trouvé que c'était
pour ça ouais ben j'ai quand même eu
j'ai quand même eu trois maisons une au
maroc une dans la leur de lait diminue
cglu comme amy sène
banon à 220 son parti y'a plus rien
arrêt bronze j'ai vécu cinq ans au
brésil après voilà moi je trouve que
c'est fait pour ça la vie hein c'est
pour flamber ben on ne sait pas ce qui
nous attend la preuve regardez du jour
au lendemain c'est parce que vous êtes
bagarreur petit coquin il a d'ailleurs
fait vous avez parlé d'une anecdote
terrible où vous retrouvez à la mairie
du 18e pour une allocation adulte
handicapé et à ces dames da commissions
qui vont regarder qu'ils disent mais
c'est le mec de sous le soleil c'est sûr
qu'il doit être pété de pognon qu'est-ce
qu'il en [ __ ] ici quoi ouais ça c'est
papa chez au service social de la mairie
du xviiie cette histoire existe non ça
s'est passé quand je suis allé à la mdph
pour wii se tromper tranquillement le
reconnaissent comme une personne
handicapée voilà là effectivement il y
avait de ce cliché tout le temps à
chaque fois de l'acteur et
multimilliardaire mais en même temps j
peux pas leur en vouloir je dirais ne me
reconnaissais je me voyais à la télé
elle se disait qu est ce qui vient
[ __ ] ici a demandé vous leur avez
expliqué messieurs non parce que en fait
je les entends départ j'étais en plein
vacarme ah oui ça m'a été répété après
oui mais bon je leur en veux pas je sais
pas alors j'ai un texto de tenues qu'ils
aient guerre qui vous fait un très gros
bisous à tous les deux c'est génial en
lui rend honteux rodez et moi j'aimerai
savoir jolie david voilà où est ce qu'on
peut vous voir jouer
voilà je vainement au premier rang un
spectacle magnifique depuis trois ans
qui s'est arrêté malheureusement avec
locaux vides pendant un an et demi donc
il en apprentissage il reprend je joue
d'ailleurs au mémorial de la shoah ça
c'est un truc qui m'a
14 mai pour les nuits des musées ils
m'ont appelé m'ont dit est ce que ce que
ça vous plairait de venir jouer ce texte
qui est vraiment sublime de gilles segal
voile avec cette manne du meilleur
spectacle avignon ouais c'est pas rien
pour ceux qui connaissent ouais c'est
vrai on est on est sur la même
thématique que la vigne que la vie est
belle de beni mais c'est magnifique et
ça c'est notre spectacle que je les
jouais en même temps avignon je veux
rejouer deux
de mise en scène de christophe lidon
pièces de michael sadler sur le brix it
une comédie sociale sentimentale mais ça
se sent joli très sincèrement mais je
trouve que vous faites vous avez l'air
devant une personnalité très riche
ces jeux je ne sais pas
le physique de deux oui c'est pas censé
aider comment vieilli mais pareil je
trouve que l'eurusd ce que je fais je
sois là l'euro se bat ça se voit mon
métier je jamais être sur les planchers
et c'est vrai que sur l'ancienne m'a
fait m'a fait passer un peu autre chose
m'a fait me donner confiance en moi
encore plus est jugé plus je passe des
caps voilà vraiment agréable et frédéric
donc vous retrouve sa transformation en
scène il est où comment il est où il
était au théâtre du gymnase pendant huit
mois oui et maintenant il va être
avignon avignon et on met ensemble enfin
on sera ensemble il y aura aussi
marie-christine adam ouais ça va
vraiment être sous le soleil avignon là
pour le coup pas si on est quand même
trois protagonistes de sous le soleil
est ce que je voulais dire
j'écoutais david parlait de son seul en
scène et
jeudi jeudi un seul ancien transforme un
comédien très bien absolument parce que
je trouve que c'est l'essence même je
sais pas j'y connais pas grand chose je
suis pas quelqu'un qui vient du théâtre
mais moi ça va ça a changé ma vie eh ben
on ira vous voir en tout cas avignon
enfin j'espère si je fus avignon ils
sont guerre civile soit d'avoir été un
déclic